[Music]
what was your favorite reaction from the
fans of the series maybe something you
didn't even expect
obviously i could never predict where
they're gonna go with
the theories you know what i'm saying
the fan theories um
i gotta admit the run i feel bad for
wyatt
but the degree to which the him becoming
the man and the cap that everyone loved
to hate
and sort of the memes that were made on
it like there was one guy who every week
did a different captain i i can't repeat
them on this this thing but
calling him captain every other
everything other than america
that that was a trip because it just
exploded and it just seemed like
the almost like the dominant thing that
came out of it
they will never let a black man
be captain america so you're pleasantly
surprised at
how well people are responding to the
themes and the topics that we
really embedded in the storyline and uh
they seem to be responding very well to
those and that was
the most important thing for all of us
making the show was that
uh you know there was a really a great
water cooler conversation that was
happening at the same time
um and of course with the twists and
turns that we were building in
that water cooler conversation was even
more uh
pronounced because you know we were
taking it sideways and we went that the
other way
and so um uh the fact that people
have embraced it and such minutia is
fantastic that's a conversation
and you know that was the intention was
to start a conversation keep a
conversation going
because this is a conversation that
should never stop so at the end of the
series we get this title card that says
captain america and the winter soldier
and i had a lot of questions about this
because
i was like okay so what does this mean
for bucky he's keeping the winter
soldier thing now we finally got sam as
captain america
is there anything you can kind of reveal
about what that title meant because a
lot of fans had a lot of questions about
it
it's funny like i'd have to ask marvel
if they expected people to be
as triggered by the bucky part of it the
winter soldier part of it
meaning i think if this is my opinion
when i first saw it um it was the idea
for marvel
i think the spirit of it came from
simply wanting to
honor the journey of the series
and had they said captain america and
james
bucky barnes the poetry of what this
series meant
might not have landed through something
as simple as text it's hard to capture
what this meant so i don't at all think
they're implying i believe
personally and i only know as far as
what we did on this series
bucky has gone through his battle and
his test
and has now emerged with a clean slate
and the winter soldier
in my opinion is gone unless something
else happened right
i don't think that the saying captain
american winter soldier was intended to
even
trigger the fans in that way it was it
was just
the spirit of it was to show this
evolution that a new cap is born
they wanted to keep some of the title
intact
so that you would get that evolution
nice job cap
thanks i can say that it was thrilling
to be able to put
captain america and we had built it you
know the decision of titles you know
that's a post-production thing so you
you get to
see the whole series and see where it
wants to sit so there was a lot of
conversation
about that title the design of it the
the nature of
even how it came on the subtlety of it
um
for for all of the where it came on
after after the tease and so on
so you know these are very thought
through um they're not random at all
and then somewhere once we've seen all
six
um i think it was probably kevin who
said you know we should put it at the
end
it really came out the whole idea of it
came out very organically and to be able
to put
captain america was um i think for all
of us kind of a proud moment
now this is more like it
it's the same but black
so i'm curious about how you feel about
john walker's kind of journey at the end
there because he did have that
redemption moment and we see him in his
new suit and
fans are wondering kind of like did he
get off too easy is everyone really cool
with him
by the series end is there anything you
can tell us about kind of like
where he's at at the end of the show we
tried to be careful with walker because
and wyatt took everything
and made it so nuanced beyond like there
was no way to write
the layers to walker the way wyatt
conveyed them
like he surpassed anything that you
could try and
do intellectually in your head and we
never judge john walker we never said he
was the bad guy
we never said he was the embodiment of
only bad things
there's definitely some iconography and
some
attributes about this country that we
don't like that are embodied in him
but he is also the story of of uh
of veterans right who sacrificed so much
for this country
and this country may not even be capable
of taking care of them the way they
should you know what i'm saying
so all those conversations are in the
dna of john walker and by the end of
this thing
we didn't set out to say john walker
will be good or bad or redeemed by the
end of this
we put him through this journey and as
he was cracking up he had this
mentally he had this huge defining
moment
where the truth is for
all the flaws and craziness of him
in that moment when it was about taking
on the righteous cause
he stepped up in that moment at the same
time
i don't think we let him off the hook
his career has been destroyed
um for someone who has dedicated their
lives to the military to get anything
other than an honorable discharge
that's a big deal and look what he went
through it's not like we didn't just say
oh you're
you're if you take a surface level he
got off easy
if you watch what happened to this man
you are
not honorably discharged you're lying to
lamar's family because you feel so much
shame
you've gone half crazy to the point of
no return
and barely pulled yourself out of that
you know i'm saying
i i don't think that is a gene easy
journey i think what wyatt is able to do
is sort of show that urgency and maybe
that chaotic mindset at the end
of how full throatedly he's embracing
where he's about to go in this black
costume you know what i'm saying right
or wrong
that it could feel like he got off easy
but i would not say he did
start lining up our buyers super
soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access to
government secrets prototype weapons
you name it the finale gave us a big
tease for
sharon carter who i loved seeing just
like
kick-ass in this series and her future
as the power broker how fun was it to
veer off of the source material and
craft her
future in the mcu well it was great you
know
first of all emily is super deserving as
a actress and as a character
you know it was also really great to
kind of imagine her
action sequences
because i wanted them to be really
muscular
and she worked very hard on the
choreography of those and it's a lot of
her own stunts
there's very little stunt work in there
that isn't her so it's a testimony to
not only her work but her sort of
badassery um
and the other thing about you know the
roll out of her
as power broker was to keep that
innocent face
and you know to to really sort of milk
the
where are we going with this who is she
what is she doing exactly in madrid for
and what is that about
so um i think that was particularly fun
because it was
you know the intention was to keep it
really close to our chest right to the
end
yeah we had a blast with it because it's
a the carter legacy right as sort of
like the pristine family of the mcu
right
but also emily has such
in my opinion an innocent baby face
right
to it just when you're it was just a
blast to write this character
who comes from marvel royalty
and is expected to be the princess of
marvel and kind of looks like that
just chopping people's heads off and
also
where it came from was it wasn't like
marvel said oh we're gonna destroy
the uh uh uh the carter legacy
we sat down we we when was the last time
we saw sharon
in civil war right and what happened to
her
she was completely abandoned by the
world's intelligence agencies what would
she have to do
hustle and fight and use her skills to
stay alive
and to me sharon as a character was
allowed
to grow up and the assumption she's
going to just be
good or bad or that you know we've
determined what her future is no
she's now in a position where she can go
on an interesting journey for good or
for
for better or for worse did you and
malcolm always know that
that tease was going to be the
post-credits scene or were there other
options that you guys considered
as the post-credit you know i think we
always knew
it wanted to be there but we tried it in
other places um
we try different ways of doing it one of
the things that i think is terrific not
only about marvel but about the way i i
like to work
is experimentation is as big a part of
of how we um how you find the right
fit how you find the best of the best uh
so i'm never afraid of really trying and
putting
you know just trying everything new
throwing throwing it all out right
building it all up again
um so we did try different ways of of um
but it seemed you know at the end of the
day
um we just we thought no let's just hang
on right
to the living end um to to you know
finalize
the end reveal um now we of course we
revealed it through the fight
but we had it we had a few different
swings of that and then this seemed to
be the best of the best
you're probably not gonna be able to say
anything about this but there's been a
report that you might be taking on
captain america to the big screen
i i i don't know until kevin tells me i
don't know
season two a lot of people are asking is
there anything in place right now
i have not been informed or if i would i
wouldn't be here to tell you so
that's when kevin when kevin says it
then it is you've been dodging these all
day huh
yeah you know it's my prerogative to ask
it's your prerogative not even to answer
no no it's it's it's all good i'm being
pretty strict about not even
the the spoiler thing because sometimes
i try and be too cute and i'm like i was
not as slick as i thought i was so
i'm spoiler free today you know uh
i i honestly don't know i never believe
you that the headlines is all i can tell
you you never know from marvel what's uh
as you as
you well know you never know from marvel
what they're going to do next so
it'll all be a surprise